yeah like each maybe like three times
yesterday so I'm pretty sure like he's
normal
I mean alright he's like 20 minutes late
you should be here soon though no I know
I'll let you know exactly every detail
Oh oh my gosh no he just sat down um
he's like reddish hair
1 to 10 probably like a four and a half
do you think yeah that's for like I
would probably take him home and be like
mom this is my friend I can hear I can
hear every word you're saying yeah no
I'll call you later all right bye
sorry hey that's okay it's great to meet
you oh my god it's so dull are you you
look so different than your avatar yeah
that's my dog I might say my dog yeah
I'm not really good with types of dogs
but I it was cute it was very cute thank
you very much
Margit Saddam so hopefully you are I'll
put it down immediately
perfect I'm sorry I'm running late this
is I didn't know where this place was
and then it looked closed from the
outside there's no I was like is this
open I mean they're open now hi hey
how's it going we don't open for another
four or five hours what sighs what what
are you talking about there's nothing
set up I mean what did you bring this
from home uh yeah no I actually brought
it from home
you brought this from home yeah these
are my glasses and this is my silver the
silver is very nice though I want to
bring plates though yeah do you guys
have plates
well you can't order anything we're
hungry leave that way that would be
really great great thanks man that guy's
an idiot he doesn't know if I brought
some things for my own refrigerator oh
good call good move like a byof
bring your own food yeah like a picnic
but like not let's talk about some it's
organic salami
perfect this is soy free lactose free
cheese
half a loaf of bread perfect
stop this I have studies show me what uh
I already started leaving these ones so
you should probably just
I don't want they're not all about
wasting sir let's just do me make you a
sandwich or something um yeah I'll help
you Han oh yeah sure mm-hmm
I've never actually made a pop chef
sandwich before so well no this one's
good yeah those look great just wanna
make sure it's on there nice I wash my
hands I'm a little nervous I'm sorry I
must have been I really I don't go on
very many dates so I don't know is this
like it I'm super nervous
it's a second typical date no I don't
ever go on dates and I'm sorry I'm
really nervous so if I pass gas that's
cuz I'm super nervous
well um so so what do we do now
on this date I went online and I read
that I went on bro bro bro codes net and
it said bro code number one if she shows
up and she and she's cool with you you
got to take her in the parking lot and
make out I'm not saying that that's like
what that's like the next step for us
but I don't do this enough to know what
the next steps are well there's actually
no parking lot here yeah I had to park
on the street do you drive do you I
don't have a license so anyway I mean
tell me a little bit about yourself like
are you from here do you know I'm
actually from uh I was from the East
Coast and my family and I were headed
west year and one day my dad and I went
out and we we tried to kill a bunch of
oxen and we had too much and the meat
spoiled and it was too much weight and
we broke two wagon wheels then we tried
to forge a river without it when we were
warned you know if you try to force this
and you might you know something might
go bad and something went bad and
everybody died I was left with my musket
oh so by the time I made it to Oregon it
was just like Oh [__] oh wait a
minute are you driving with Oregon Trail
what like the computer game the computer
game Oregon Trail what are you talking
about what are you talking about I just
gave you my life story it just gave me
the plotline for the game Oregon Trail
are you telling me someone took my life
and made it a video game no I'm telling
you us that would the video game and
meeting your life and I believed it for
a solid 20 seconds
I'm being serious that was my life was
your dad a banker yeah that's a-- and my
mom was a banquette
you took our delicious I know you want
to get out of here
I do actually what I hear what I don't
oh you're gonna leave
whichever computers you have a little I
had Speak & Spell and that's it just
like one of them but when you go the
potatoes are cheddar potatoes are my
favorite all right thank you I'll hear
that sounds good
you